hello YouTube just lowers my friends
this is grunge in here once again I like
to welcome you for my chess reputa
against efore in this lecture we are
going to see how to defuse the Goering
gambit after the Mordor efore nc6 d4
ePHI white can enter into the scotch
cave via Knight to f3 here I propose
that that should capture the D pawn and
in last few lectures we look at the move
Bishop to c4 which is known as Scotch
gambit in this lecture we are going to
see another gambit idea by white that is
known as going gambit and start with the
MU c3
now before we look at deeper into the
going gambit there is one thing I like
to mention is the occurrence of this
gambit is pretty rare the simplest
reason is black can easily equalize
early in the opening and I am playing
this nc6 system from last two years or
so and together I face only ten games in
the going gambit so you can easily
conclude that this is not a base system
from white even though you are expecting
this things from the lower rated
opponents now capturing the c3 pawn is
perfectly viable but in those cases
black has to face the onslaught of the
white which is something I don't like
instead of that I am recommending a line
which will not only equalize black only
in the opening stage but it is the black
who is having all the fun the move I am
proposing is d5 so counter attacking in
the center the amount of games I have
played there are four different options
tried by the white now the main move
here is e captures V file but before
looking at that let's look at the side
lines first the first move I am going to
consider is Bishop to d3
against this blacks should continue with
the move Bishop to g4 and in this game
my opponent castle on the kingside and I
replied with the move Knight to f6 he
played the move Luke - even and I played
the move Bishop to himself so I just
want to castle on the kingside here my
opponent aggressively played the movie
Phi so I dropped my knight back to the
d7 and now he played Bishop to f4 I
castle on the Kings side and now he
played a very tricky move that is C
captures d4
at first sight it looks like this one is
hanging but actually it's not
after few calculations I captured the D
pole and my opponent's idea was to give
me this Shack and when I captured the
bishop he regained the peace but doing
so he forget that his King side points
will be ruined after the ship captures
f3 and this is exactly the consequence
of this life my opponent has to capture
this bishop now I simply reconsolidate
my D pawn with the move
c6 you can already see material is
balanced but black king is quite safe
where white keying side points are all
over the place
my opponent continued with the MU ecigs
I capture the e pawn and when he
captured with the rook I played the move
Bishop to f6 my opponent dropped bags to
Queen to the d2 and now another tactics
I simply capture the b2 pawn
why doesn't have any choice white has to
accept this and now I regain the piece
back with the move rook captures f4
hear my opponent plate looked back to
the even but after Queen check came to
h1 there is no need to look at this game
in the father which I initially won not
only white King side pawns are shattered
but black has the wonderful majority in
the center and look at the Queen side
piece of the white they are yet to be
developed so all in all it was a
wonderful game for me
the second mood try by my opponent is
night captures d4 here black has a very
simple move that is D captures efore and
no matter however white plays white will
not gain anything
now the first obvious move is Knight
captures c6 but after Queen captures
Queen and King captures when black
regained the piece even though blacks
pawn are double on the Queen side black
emerge with a clear upon up so I don't
believe in this line what white is
getting after all this
so obviously Knight capture c6 is not a
good move
in one game with a higher ranked player
my opponent responded with the move
Queen to e4 I responded with Bishop to
d7 and his idea is to play Bishop to b5
so now it's pressurizing the c6 square
but here I simply play Knight captures
d4 and removing all the tactics
my opponent is pointed with the move C
captures d4 and now I played a six so
doing a clarification about the pin my
opponent captured the bishop and when I
recapture if I would able to exchange
the Queen then black is a clear pawn up
so my opponent wisely played the move
Queen to c4 but after this the game
become very easy so I castle on the
Queen side so now there's a threat on
the d4 so my opponent defended with the
move Bishop to e3 and now I consolidate
my Center with the move FY my opponent
continues with the move castling on the
King side and after Bishop to d6 Knight
to c3 Knight to d7
once again not only black has finished
his development but black is a clear
horn up and in the game I converted my
advantage into the winning one
the third move which try by few of my
opponent which is the move e5 but I
don't believe in this move because this
can be simply refuted with the MU D
capture c3 so now black can accept the
spawn sacrifice because now why doesn't
have any aggressive line after night
capture c3 and Bishop to b4 there's a
threat of default push so my opponent
played the move Bishop to d2 afterwards
black can continue with the move Bishop
to g4 and you can see how free peas
develop and black is having all the
white is doing his defense nothing else
hear my opponent responded with the move
Bishop to e2 after the move d4 black has
a clear advantage
my opponent thought that I'm mistaken
something so he captured the pawn I
captured the piece and now he captured
my bishop but after all this black and
play the move Knight captures e5
not only black remain upon up but with
the back requisition here my opponent
pinned that night with the move Queen to
e2 but I continued my piece development
with the move Knight to f6 my opponent
dropped bishop back to the f3 i castle
on the Queen side and you can already
see this is a disaster position for
white here my opponent castle on the
Queen side but after Knight Jack King to
b1 and Queen captures c2
I bet my opponent was usually
disappointed
the game continues with the move Bishop
to e1 I capture the Queen my opponent we
capture with the bishop
I captured the bishop - recaptured with
the rook I captured the knight my
opponent capture with the pawn I
captured the rook my opponent capture
with the rook and finally I played the
move rook to the edge and it's time for
assessment not only black is a clear two
points off but a better pawn structure
with a clearly winning advantage
so those are some of the sidelines which
white can try and you can feel now very
confident that they are not good at all
so now we are in turning into the
mainline stuff with start with the movie
captures d5
here black should certainly capture the
deep on and now once again the mainline
runs with the move C captures d4 now
black has many choices but I am going to
recommend one simplest system which can
not only defuse all the aggression of
white but it can give black a slight
edge which you can convert into the
winning one here I propose that you
should play the move Knight to f6 now
the main move over here is Knight to c3
which we are going to pin that night
with the move Bishop to b4 and now there
are few moves has been trialed once
again the main move over here is Bishop
to e2 but let's look at the lines for
example in one of my game my opponent
tried the move Bishop to d3 but this is
a ugly move because now black can
respond with the move Bishop to g4 in
order to stop getting double pawns White
has to waste some time and place the
move Bishop to e2 in that case black and
decide either queenside castle or the
King side castle with a wonderful
position to boot
the second move I can try is Queen tui
to check but against this that can
simply reply with the move Bishop to e6
and now the problem is there's a deep on
hanging and not only that Queen to e2
has stopped the development of the Kings
side Bishop I won a very quick game in
the game my opponent responded with the
move Bishop to e3 so defending the d4
pawn and I renew the threat while the MU
queenside castling the problem for my
opponent was he liked to castle on the
Queen side but then Bishop captures c3
and White King side castle will be
ruined so considering that my opponent
played the move rook to d8 protecting
the d4 once again but after this the
task become very very easier for me so I
played the move Bishop to g4 and you can
see that hopeless King it's still stuck
in the center and that annoying Queen is
stopping all the King side piece
development I don't know what my
opponent was thinking at this point but
he simply played to move a 3 which is
again a nothing moved because I simply
capture the night and after he
recaptured I played the most natural
looking move that his rook h2h and white
can already pack in and go home my
opponent continues with the move s free
but this is just asking for it I
captured the knight my opponent capture
with the Queen so probably he's hoping
that now I can develop my bishop and
castle on the King side but I put break
to all of his plants while the move
Queen to e5 so now there's a threat of
capturing the c3 pawn so my opponent
defended with the move rook to c1 but my
next move shatter the dreams of the
white so I played Knight captures d4
so Quinn has to move and in the game my
opponent plays Quinn to g3 but after the
simplest move Queen captures a three
it's seriously a reasonable position my
opponent continues for a while so he
played rook to d1
but now I finish him off with a style so
I played Quinn check he played rook to
d2 then once again Quinn check and after
rook to d1 night to say - king - II -
Quinn cap - Stephen as a checkmate so
white need to be very very careful if
he's playing moves such as Queen - e -
check
so considering all this it's very
obvious that main move over here is
Bishop to e2 but after this black can
play the move Knight to e4 which more or
less force black to play Bishop to d2
and now the whole plying of the black is
very very simple what black is going to
do is first of all capture the knight
doesn't matter black capture with the
pawn or the bishop let's say the main
line is capturing with the pawn now we
are going to snap up that Bishop and
after white we capture simply castle on
the Kings side and when White Castle on
the Kings side the very important move
and which you should always remember
Queen to d6
the simplest reason is c4 does not come
up with the temple and
because there is no dark square bishop
for white black queen is quite safe 186
square
I get two interesting games in this line
so we should see both of them in the
first game my opponent tried to move
immediate c4 so he wants to advance on
the queenside as quickly as possible I
responded with the move Bishop to g4 and
now he played a premature move that is d
file
it's very important to remember that
whenever you open and play the move defy
only now you are going to capture the
night the simplest reason is now the
white bishop will become very bad bishop
in this position white cannot capture
the night so my opponent has to capture
the bishop afterwards the natural move
Knight to e5 he played Bishop to e2 and
now another important move that is b6
so stopping any sea fire once my
opponent replied with the move rook to
c1 and i centralized my rook with the
move rook to e8 my upon I responded with
the move rook to d1 and here I played
the move rook to e7 so my idea is very
simple I just want to double my roof on
the e-file and then look forward for the
right opportunity at this point my
opponent feel somewhat desperate and he
tried the move f4 but this doesn't turns
out well for white I played first of all
Queen check and after king - h1 I
retrieve my knight to the d7 sprayer my
opponent thought that he has some
tactics so he played the move d6 but
this is over-ambitious i simply captured
the pawn and when white captured the
pawn back I captured a piece
the simple reason is after Queen
captures and rook - eh now black is
threatening to play Queen to f2 with a
very good position so my opponent
realized that and he stopped with the
group to have fun saying no tactics I
played a careful looking move that is at
six giving my king somewhat hair and so
did he so he played the more h3 now I
really put the booty so I played the
move rook to e3 running out of the
plants and seeing my pieces coming
closer to his King my opponent wants to
exchange the Queen so he played the move
Queen to b5 but after Queen to see it
there are some nasties looming on the h3
square my opponent thought that he can
easily diffuse all this while the MU F
Phi but can you believe rook h3 was on
the card now here my opponent was
shocked it took around 10 minutes and he
come to a conclusion that capturing the
rook will be a disaster for white let's
see this if white captures the spot rook
then the simplest is pintubi H and there
is no stopping on the catch - square
my opponent played to move King to g1
but after this black can play the move
Queen to be it so now there's a threat
of Queen to h2 which I don't think so
white can parry so my opponent try to
defuse all the mating attack while the
move rook I have to but now
Queen to h2 check came to a phone and
now I give you a few seconds can you see
am eighteen nine
you can pause the video and you can look
for a for it I'm showing you right now
the first move black should play is
capturing the rook and after king takes
back now black can give this check which
is Queen to f4 and the following
sequence which goes like this so my
opponent plays king - II - I played
Queen - III check my opponent place came
to d1 but after rook check came to see -
rook captures rook came to be - Queen to
c3 as a checkmate
so that is one good game which highlight
what you should do if you offer in place
immediate sequel in the second game
where my opponent was really high rated
he continues with the MU look to be one
I responded with the moon v6 now he
played the MU rook to even and I
responded with the moon at six so b6 and
s6 are prophylactic mu seeing no
clear-cut plans my opponent responded
with the MU s free but here I can finish
my development with the move Bishop to a
file attacking the rook so my opponent
played the move Bishop to d3 here I
exchanged the bishops and play the
simplest move rook to even
my opponent thought that I am looking
for a drawers so he tried to become
aggressive and he played the move see
for sooner or later if white wants to
get anything out of this game he has to
push the c4 and that is exactly we want
because we can always target those loose
phones as soon as I see the c4 I was
delighted and I played the move rook to
b8 pressurizing the d4 pawn which my
opponent doesn't like it so he advanced
the pawn to the defy as soon as the pawn
goes to the defy the knight always comes
to the e-file and my opponent capture
the knight here I recapture with the
rook after some thinking my opponent
played the MU King to have fun so his
idea is to exchange all the rooks and
then do something with those advanced
phones I responded here with the move
rook to e8 and my opponent executed his
plan so he captured the first rook and
when I recaptured he put the second rook
but this turns out as a mistake for the
white because now black can capture this
rook and after King takes Queen - if I
check will be very very little
no matter how why responded in the game
my opponent responded with the move
Queen to e2 but after Queen to even
check Queen to d1 Queen to c3 not only
white lose the vital pawn on the c4 but
it creates the majority for the black on
the Queen side which in the long run
will be decisive and that is exactly
happen in the game for some complication
I managed to win so that's it that's all
the information you need to defuse the
goring gambit I hope you enjoy and learn
this wonderful lecture feel free to like
and comment on this video and I'll meet
you in my next chapter
bye